The xenophobic nationalists, right.
Loves to talk about how none of these immigrants
can assimilate in the United States.
They bring their own language, they bring
their own culture.
They bring their own skin color.
Wait, okay, wait.
Maybe that last one there at least not supposed
to say out loud.
Anyway, the nationalists love to talk about
how immigrants from Latin America or the Middle
East or Asia basically from anywhere other
than Europe, they just can't assimilate here
or they choose not to or they don't have the
cognitive capacity to do it.
They can't successfully integrate themselves
into the American mill, you and culture, so
say the conservative nationalists.
I want to flip this around.
I want to make the case that it's the conservative
nationalists who are unable to assimilate
to the reality of 2019 United States of America.
There's a really good article on reason.com
about this.
The way the argument usually goes is people
come here from other countries.
They change the fabric of the country.
They make it something else, something other
than what we believe it is supposed to be,
and next thing you know, we'll be living under
Sharia law or Spanish will be the national
language of the United States or whatever,
which is a very popular but also completely
bogus slippery slope argument that the conservative
nationalists just love to make.
The reality is that it is them.
It's the conservative nationalists who are
enabled to assimilate to the reality of a
life.
In the USA.
In 2019 the United States was founded on principles
that these extremist, conservative nationalists
enclaves simply cannot accept or adapt to.
Imagine a community that rallies around the
confederate flag, the opposite of what the
United States stands for and represents those
groups that look at the confederacy, that
fought for slavery in the civil war.
They look at that era as the golden era.
They're not assimilated to the modern reality
of the United States.
They don't fit here.
That's the reality.
The immigrant from Guatemala who comes to
New York City and goes to school while working
in a restaurant is far more assimilated to
the ideals and values of the United States.
Then conservative nationalists who in their
minds are still living in the 18 hundreds
of the United States.
It's not even a close call, like there's not
even a debate to be had about who is actually
assimilated here in the United States.
There's this revival of a sort of nationalist,
conservative, rural white identity and you
don't have to check every single one of those
boxes to be part of it.
That is simply on assimilated to the reality
of the 2019 United States of America.
They do not fit here.
Their culture, conservative nationalists culture
runs counter to that of the United States
at large.
Now, yes, I understand that there are parts
of the country, uh, where it's not obvious
that it runs counter, uh, but the truth is
that their culture runs counter to that of
the United States.
Their language, including the terms that they
use and how they talk about issues runs counter
to the way that the United States of America
is increasingly talking about issues.
Their views certainly run counter to the foundational
views and values of the United States.
Why is it that they can't accept that they
live in the United States and accept the principles
on which the country was founded and to assimilate
and get in line?
They say that that's what the immigrants are
supposed to do.
I say that's what they should do.
Assimilate, instead of talking about kicking
people out, assimilate, instead of talking
about building walls or using racial slurs,
and in fact there's actually an irony, much
of the confederacy simply didn't want to be
part of the United States and based on their
total lack of assimilation in the modern day,
maybe they still don't want to be part of
what the United States actually is.
Consider that immigrants value education in
modern day 2019 USA much more than these conservative
nationalists who see it instead as some form
of liberal indoctrination for those fancy
schmancy liberals.
The view of the immigrant on education is
by and large, far more assimilated to the
values of the United States.
Then the view of education that the conservative
nationalists hold, you have in this coalition,
conservative nationalist coalition, a bitter
and angry and entitled Group of people that
is just refusing to accept the country, not
for what they fear it is becoming, but for
what it actually is and has always been a
melting pot.
I know it's Cliche, but it's a melting pot
that they want to be the sole beneficiaries
of not people that look different from them
or that have different cultural backgrounds
or different views about education, quite
frankly.
And my message to them is if they can't assimilate,
what are they doing?
What are they planning to do?
Because the answer to that question may actually
be extraordinarily disturbing and dystopian.
Donald Trump said, if you don't like it, leave.
It's interesting that it's not being applied
to the conservative nationalists who increasingly
are completely on assimilated here in the
United States of America.
Let me know what you think.
I know many of you will.